Affairs yeah so we are really fortunate
though to have her here over Zoom to
give her presentation
um and I think in the interest of time
Anastasia I'll go ahead and just pass
things over to you maybe you can say
something we can make sure the volume is
working okay
here
can you see it again sorry
can you hear me can you all hear that
okay yeah okay yeah okay okay
thank you very much for inviting me and
thank you very much
I have some different issues and in this
talk I'm going to talk about conversions
on price and December the correlated
noise and applications to differentiate
with private learning we treat it
together with Ryan
in Collaborative Learning privacy is an
issue and the frequently available to be
cooperative learning in settings when
your data sets like when the data are
quite sensitive
like it needs some privacy protections
and one of the ways how to ensure
privacy is to use the differential
private initiative
and I'm gonna I'm not gonna
give her like a good Avenue I think you
saw it yesterday and I will just give a
simple uh simplified version of how like
a simplified description of higher it
works
uh for the purpose of the stock and uh
yeah so so in differential privacy so we
have some clients and these clients we
compute like yeah so how to support
yourself from some uh model X so this is
our parameters once again and uh like
like this clients or like notes we start
to complete gradients and they work for
data sets xci uh so this is like a new
device when we click this guidance when
some aggregation of his guiding happens
in some ways
uh like for example secure aggregation
and to this like aggregated gradient uh
like some noise some privacy noise is
getting added to ensure uh with the
guidance of pilot
I'd like to hide some information or
like in this sentence and then so this
prioritize guidance case and applied to
the eateries with some step size and
this procedure continuous and it could
be summarized quickly like like in a
short way uh so at our iteration we just
apply some like targeted guidance
there's some noise
and
like as you saw yesterday in Peter's
talk uh in like if you want to apply
like it in Collaborative Learning
computers
uh so like uh like like frequencies
uh we would need to do some
amplification techniques uh and this is
called the PHD and this amplification
techniques like for example
multiplication by sampling it requires
what all the clients available like all
the time because uh like we need to be
able at everybody
for example every client with positive
probability which is not uh like so
practical in practice is not what
happens and we could use unamplify the
PHD and the noise that we add and the
preparation with the large would have
large magnitude and so it told about it
yesterday so we proposed this uh General
style of algorithms but don't use any
amplification techniques and vehicle
relate noise or reparation in such a way
with uh like like the last iteration so
we know yeah like here like maybe I
should repeat it in this algorithm
preparation the noise is ID and it's a
independent from the previous voice and
in this uh like algorithm when you are
supposed to related over iterations and
it's related in such a way with the last
iteration like some part of the noise
before got removed and so we should wait
for like six privacy levels like the
Epsilon is like some privacy parameter I
use like this algorithm can achieve a
better performance when un Amplified
application and sometimes even better
than Amplified initiative
looks like uh so like just to remind
dphgd at every iteration like add some
guidance and
can you make advice so the teacher is
unfair recognized and
one degree
and like we would need to scale this by
some sensitivity parameter uh in order
to ensure what the Privacy is the same
and so like in this form like if you
have graduate messages for
uh for any correlation pattern B we
would have exactly the same privacy
and with sensitivity how to compute it
like it was done in these papers I'm not
going to focus here on on this question
and the question is so like we have like
this relation patterns B with all of
them will give the same privacy and this
one should be used to get the best
optimization so what's your question
um
and the whole Pride like how this works
how did they do it and I have uh some
conclusions upper bound and like we have
some parameter I or B
yeah like some function of B which will
minimize and this is how we get uh like
like very very thick discriminate the
schedules BMF uh like as the ones that
minimize this upper bound uh like uh
[Music]
we will get a performance
and the problem this this is only in
this conversion state is what this
conversion of rate is not type and it
doesn't travel conversions in some
special cases for example if this
unpretrelated pattern just classical
music
uh this conversion so it would not
recover like for best conversion state
of HDD in this case
how this relation patterns be effective
civilization and will derive the type of
convenience rate but not sure directly
some important special cases and uh so
and it depends also like different like
different function fit out
uh and the star is a
is like some hyper parameters
and the style measures uh how like how
many map iterations uh like between how
many operations correlations are still
metal and after like after Tower
iterations if you edit some words before
it's uh effectively uncorrelated uh and
based on our new uh conversion Theory to
introduce a new schedules but in math
hour
a new computer space
and we
estimated within practice on sci-fi fan
deficit and we see it was for all like
parameters like privacy parameters
Epsilon I will propose the MF plus
improves
consistently over previous DPMS like the
PSL
um and uh so now we want it also to
understand
uh like on simple like
in simple settings
why do we have such Improvement like
very consistent and uh so what's
reported
is average error so this is what when
the analysis
for what we give conversion States and
like we run different learning phase and
like look forward
and uh
we see what uh for like our new like
other DPM of class it uh like
consistently I will say no better I
could have I will say more better laws
which which is consistent with the
theory uh however in practice was
produced in like usually every members
every single rate which is usually
velocity rate and especially in
differential privacy
and we see what interestingly for the
last iterative performance uh dpmo plus
improves even more some and sometimes it
goes for learning rates where average
internet is not improved like for
example here
um and so we're also excited about some
inversion behavior and we see like we're
interested in Behavior but like every
time tau is our discoloration for
anything and then here I'm going to put
Tower from the kids we see with every
Tower iterations loss like Tylenol so I
was consistency degrees
and so this is this is ensures but the
last decorate also in previous or also
is better so the last error is good and
the services like a lot of like it is an
interesting question about analyzing
this type of algorithms in terms of
plastic and detector
okay and to summarize and so we type
here like remote typing analyzed
Behavior under a credibility press
patterns we propose the new schedules
based on our Theory and we observe an
interesting Behavior where velocity
right iterates
conversions
and it would be interesting to study and
why it happens no
[Applause]
any questions for anesthesia
one quick I just wanted to clarify one
thing so you mentioned the tighter
convergence uh behavior in special cases
are the special cases specifically these
cases with correlated noises where you
have a specific parameter Tau there for
the delay or what were the special cases
where you get improvements
yeah so special cases what we considered
is when we have uh like non-con like
uncondulated noise so B can be any
information pattern right
so it would be saying uh ft as you did
and in our
calculated pattern we used is what we
add like at every next operation we
would exactly subtract all the noise
which we added in previous operations
okay okay got it
okay great I think we'll have um next we
have Peter ektarik from from cast giving
a talk so let's think Anastasia again
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thanks a lot for having me so I'll talk
about something which uh
which Nadi already uh alluded to a
little bit about the strength of local
training to do something nice for us in
Fair learning and the stuff I actually
mentions the local training is probably
a communication acceleration mechanism
and I have special slide which I managed
to prepare just for Native based on what
I saw on his slides so this is the uh
this is the optimal method in the
homogeneous heterogeneous case uh which
also beats mini batch SGD in in the
setup where these distributed these
parallel workers have different uh types
of of computation
uh but I'm not going to talk about this
so this is just a very clear very very
quick uh very quick planet today it's a
recent work of us this is cast uh the
collaborators for the line of work that
motivated this this talk most of our
members of former members of my team but
there's also some other people in here
all right so let's start with what is
local training I only have couple slides
on this just to get everybody on the
same page in order to be able to do that
let's formalize what we mean by uh
optimization or federal learning in this
case we want to be minimizing the
average over a certain number of clients
uh we are working with d-dimensional
vectors this is parametrizing the the
model that was trained and these
functions could be expectations over
some distributions which are allowed to
be arbitrarily different I'm not going
to be making any assumptions on any kind
of similarity between these functions
however I will talk about the smooth and
strongly convex case in the entire talk
I'm leaving out conveys or non-convex
cases just outside outside of this
because even in this case we didn't know
until very recently what local training
really does so this is really why I'm
focusing on that okay but I want to
stress again no assumption on data
similarity so what is these numbers
possible algorithm can think of to solve
this problem it's great in the same of
course it's dumb but it's smart in in
the way they can be improved in many
ways to make it into very very good
algorithm later on so let's work with
three workers at the moment uh the way
greater descent could be implemented is
this very simple uh algorithm here uh
XT is received by the server uh by uh
from from the server by all workers a
local copy of this XC is created every
client takes a gradient step based on
their local data and local function
that's why there's F3 here F2 here and
F1 over there after this the model is
communicated to server server just
averages these models and this just
happens to be if you do the algebra just
one gradients the sense that everything
is fine what is problematic with this
method what is problematic is that these
six arrows are very expensive and
compared to the computation time the
communication time is typically much
much more expensive so this looks like a
very badly designed method because you
spend much more time on communication
than computation so how can this be
improved so the the very simple idea
which people had roughly let's say 10
years ago or could be even 25 years ago
depend depend how you count is just use
more local training so this is what I
call by local training don't just stop
at one great and step just keep going so
the second worker keeps taking great
instance with respect to its own local
data F2 until let's say capital K local
training steps happen in this case these
are great in the sun steps and then the
resulting models are communicated server
averages them and broadcasts the model
so everybody in the process is repeated
so the question is what K should we
choose clearly we shouldn't choose K is
equal to one because we get greater than
I already said greenstone is not a good
method if you go to k Infinity there's
also a bad choice because then the
method only can find the average of the
minimizers of these functions which is
not going to be the minimizer of the
average but but practically some K which
is reasonably
chosen is much better
than just choosing case equal to one and
the question is why so here in this
paper
in this paper
uh we outline five generations of local
training methods in the smooth strongly
convex setting based on uh the
theoretical understanding of logo
training that we had at that time so the
first generation dates back to uh
roughly 10 years ago to this work and
and these other works by Philip Moritz
and Carters or Brandon McMahon this is
one of these early Fair learning papers
where uh these authors realize just
choosing K bigger than one and they've
done it in the in in the setup of SGD
not necessarily great in Ascent but as I
said even greatness setting is not
understood they realize they can speed
up the communication by factors of
between 10 to 100 so the effect is
really huge choosing K different from
one is really huge but however there was
no Theory so we didn't know at that
point in time whether this actually is
just a fluke or it's a real phenomenon
and this is what you would see if you
look at local SGD or local grade incent
in this case what you would see roughly
is that compared to Green the sandwiches
which is this blue line if you take more
than one local training steps you get
much faster convergence initially but
the method also uh gets stuck near some
in some neighborhood of the solution
much sooner so depending on the accuracy
that you're aiming for certain number of
local training sets could be better than
some other our local trains however we
don't understand at least two things on
this plot theoretically which is there's
no Theory which explains why these uh
these lines should be better than great
in Ascent all Theory later on in
generation two and and forward we're
generation one now says that the slope
should not be better than that of great
incent and also we're not happy with
these methods getting stuck so what the
subsequent Generations were trying to
resolve is these two issues things
okay so the first generation of uh our
of theoretical understanding uh relied
on this very simple intuition which is
if all the functions are homogeneous are
the same which is the setup that nothing
was focusing on in in some of his talk
then clearly taking local steps should
be beneficial in the setup of full
gradient computations right because uh
because then you should just take
infinitely many local training steps
everybody's trying to solve the same
problem you don't have to communicate at
all and everything is fine
so that's better than taking one local
grade instead so so you would do some
sort of sensitivity analysis on this so
for instance with this boundary grain
diversity uh inequality or assumption
one would say if C is one you you think
of these local data sets as being
identical if C goes to Infinity you
allow more and more heterogeneity but
you're going to pay for that
heterogeneity and the results in these
papers which I'm not really mentioning
here they deteriorate quickly as the
level of heterogeneity goes to arbitrary
heterogeneity and then you get
nonsensical results saying the local
training should not help at all however
that is not what practitioners of
serving practice local training would
help even with arbitrary levels of
heterogeneity so these kinds of results
were not satisfying for that reason then
uh the second the third generation
is the generation where no assumptions
on any level of uh homogeneity or
bounded heterogeneity were made so uh
with damage colored and constant in
Mission Co we managed to prove that
local grain sand actually converges it
converges however at the worst rate and
great incent okay so that is very
disappointing but we didn't need any
assumptions on homogeneity so it does
really work it's not the heuristic
however it's the worst method so this
clearly again is not answering the
question why local government descent is
better because in because it says it's
worse but in practice is better so
that's not satisfying the fourth
generation of methods which was started
by size work and and Cutters
these scaffold paper and some other
works from from my lab and subsequent
works of other people I even I can't
read this uh on here
they removed the the the the the
neighborhood convergence by by throwing
in some drip reduction mechanism
so what happens here that you get the
same rate of gradient descent not faster
than greater than sand but compared to
the generation before Generation 3 which
gets stuck around some neighbor in some
neighborhood of the solution generation
four just keeps going and you get the
linear convergence rate what you would
expect under else smooth and and
strongly convex setup okay so that is
all fine however the rate is still not
better than a great incent so the steer
would tell you just don't take more
local grading steps or if you take
thousand local grading steps create make
every local make every step size
thousand times smaller than the grain
descent step size and then uh that's how
you should run the method that's that's
what the theory predicted and that's why
the theory says you get the same
performance and as great and set so this
is the best we knew at that time however
it's still not fully satisfying because
obviously the method is better than this
in practice by huge margin so we still
were missing something very fundamental
so this brings us to the fifth
generation of local training methods
where we could prove that in fact what's
happening is that this is not just a
fluke it's not just coincidence that
local training helps you can prove it
and what's really happening is that you
go from condition number dependence to
square root of condition number
dependence just like with a poliag or an
ester of acceleration under suitable
assumption so this is really what local
training does if it's executed in the
right way
all right so this is the paper where we
managed to show this and if you if you
can read the title there's three
exclamation marks in the title we're
thinking about this for quite some time
and so we're happy that we could we
could uh resolve this so the form of
theorem looks something like this I go
very quickly through it if the number of
iterations which is communication uh
these are iterations not Communications
iterations is at least condition number
and Max the condition number and one
over P Square with where p is going to
be the probability of communication
and it can be anything between zero and
one times log 1 over Epsilon then
certainly happening function gets pushed
below Epsilon to the opponent function
involves the convergence to the optimal
solution which is necessarily unique
because we assume strong complexity and
these are some kind of dual control
variates for drift reduction so they
also converge to Optimal dual variable
now if you just look at this result you
would see that choosing P being one is
definitely not a good idea and P being
one would mean you communicate in every
single iteration that would mean you
just take one local gradient step and
then you communicate average one local
gradient still you average which means
with p is equal to one you get just
great incent as a special case of this
but if L over mu is huge then P being
equal to 1 is definitely not going to be
the bottling in this Max so you should
choose one over P Square exactly
matching L over mu and this gives you
the optimum formula for p and the
optimum should be 1 over the square root
of condition number and that means that
you should really take square of
condition number local training steps
that's the optimal number of local
training steps and with this you only
get square root of condition number
communication routes because together
you still get square root of condition
number times square root of condition
number gradient steps which is just L
over mu gradient steps so this is really
what's going on and this is just this is
a more General result which works for
any proximal optimization
setup where you want to minimize the sum
of a smooth strongly convex function and
approximate regularizer and what we're
really doing here with this probability
P we're skipping the computation of the
proximity operator so what is really
behind this it's a variance reduction
mechanism for compressing the proximity
operator in a forward backward algorithm
this is what's really behind this even
though I don't have time to really go
into this at any depth okay
so uh so this was the first paper and
then we're inspired by this and we
started asking uh follow-up questions
can we combine this with this or this or
this or this trick and so on so we so
we're quite busy over the last year and
a half with this this will work by some
other people and uh one of the last
slides that I want to show here uh
depending how much time I have left is
this uh so we started asking questions
such as let's say can we throw in client
sampling into the equation and can we
still retain The Accelerated
communication nature of local training
with proxy we couldn't do it we tried
very hard and we couldn't do it however
we came up with a different algorithm
which we call 5gcs is the fifth
generation client sampling method which
could combine probably client sampling
with accelerated local training so that
you get the kind of rate that you'd
expect and very recently we managed to
also do this for proxkip and in this
tamuna algorithm we can do client
sampling also for proscape so then you
could ask question can you combine this
with communication compression in such a
way did you get theoretically better
communication complexity so there's all
this parallel stream of works on
reducing communication complexity by
compressing the communicated messages
not through local training and I can
give a separate talk on this and we've
done a lot of work in the direction as
well so this was the first time we're
able to show that local training plus
communication compression can be
combined and you can get the method
which is up to minimum squared of d
square root of n m squared of condition
number better than if you don't compress
the messages so so D is the
dimensionality n is the number of
clients and and Kappa is the condition
number so a minimum of these three
square root of numbers you can improve
this rate if you do communication
compression
so this all these methods support
decentralized setup which which relates
back to notice uh talk about uh
optimization over connected graphs so
you can do this on connected graphs as
well these are not time bearing graphs
but these are static graphs and uh and
some of these methods actually support
any local training methods such as this
one and this one and these other ones
support GD or SGD or some various
induced SGD I don't know how much time I
have lived but this was my last slide in
the end right here perfect yeah thanks
Peter
um
I have a quick question and we can see
if other folks have questions as well so
one question I have for you I think you
have some work on this is is what degree
you know part of the I think excitement
around using something like Federated
averaging and that cross-device setting
is when you're solving these deep
learning objectives and you see a lot of
improvements in practice do you to what
degree do you think that that is in
terms of that being useful for solving
the optimization objective versus there
being something useful in terms of
generalization when using this so I
really think it's both and here we've
purely focus on the communication act
solution aspect of this model looking at
non-convex setup or generalization but
uh there are some early works even from
my lab where we showed that the local
training could be also interpreted as
some sort of personalization and when
you do personalization you might hope
for more generalization
still the fundamental
assumptions there are not quite it's not
not quite clear what the goal of federal
learning in the setup would really be
but under those assumptions it all works
out even theoretically and so we have
also recent paper where we combine all
of this with personalization and
personalization adds yet another
acceleration a mechanism into all of
this interesting
are there any other questions from folks
yeah
gets like way back I've got kind of like
how doing multiple sets of local already
had this kind of like short slope
followed by a plateau right um and you
mentioned that I I also I think you have
some work that kind of explains this in
some settings like in certain strongly
contact settings for instance like you
can get some kind of like effective
constant that explains that behavior but
has any of your reasons
if some early works even mine which I
have ignored I didn't find mentioned so
you could partially maybe explain some
of this even without getting into the
square root but the square root really
goes to the heart of the matter because
that effect is just much larger thank
you
uh yeah maybe one quick question
can match that
uh so we don't assume any kind of
similarity here
so all of this is without any hash of
similarity uh if you add someone already
into this you'll be trying to combine
the generation two with generation five
so throwing additional assumption
narrowing down the class of functions
and then I would expect there will be
even better results
all right thanks again Peter thank you
[Applause]
so next we have Ari Rupa Saha who is a
research scientist at Apple machine
learning research
thank you
I think it's off
[Music]
am I out of it
thank you
um
uh great so thanks a lot for the
invitation firstly and because uh I
don't my background is mostly on online
learning and optimization but
um I'm like really intrigued by the
talks and the discussion that happened
yesterday it's really like a very
interesting field of work
um so in this work I will talk about
this talk I talk about joint work with
naughty and uh his students ttic uh when
I was visiting ttic last year so
um the work mostly addresses the problem
of fertility learning with distributions
ships and uh one of the so this is
actually going to be published we are
going to present it in icms so if you're
around you're happy to be talking to you
again at icml
um one of the disadvantage of giving a
dog after Natty is uh whatever I will
say it will sound like a reputation but
I can't do much about it so thankfully
Nadi did not really mention so much
about the heterogeneous model or the
fact um in the analysis about
distribution ships so I'll start with a
disclaimer and Nadia already mentioned
that it is actually we don't understand
much about this regime of the problem
where we have this heterogeneous model
or the stochastic distribution across
the machines are different uh we are
actually trying to address an even more
harder setup where the distributions are
actually shifting across times so
starting with a disclaimer that no way
we understand the complexity of the
problem the upper and lower bound very
well but this is just a small stepping
stone like a baby steps towards defining
the problem and understanding what could
be a good comparator so our results are
not even close to Optimal we are also
very self-critical about it but we would
like to take your opinions about what is
solved what can be solved what makes
sense so that's overall the stock is
going to be so foreign
of course and also one more disclaimer
for all the Privacy folks present in
this room so we are not really
addressing the privacy concerns here but
it is definitely something worth looking
at also
okay so uh I don't think I need to
actually give any motivating talk about
how Predator learning is important we
have already discussed a lot about it uh
so the only small thing I would try to
mention here is of course we know that
in healthcare recommender system
personal uh whatever autonomous driving
fraud detection image detection
everywhere this is very important I mean
this this has a huge application uh
however we have to keep in mind that uh
the distribution so we have no reasons
to believe that our uh so so if our date
if the system is like we want to make
the system more personalized if we have
our model deployed across this local
machines there is no reason to believe
that the function or the distribution uh
in this local machines are actually
stationary they might change over time
for example in personalized
recommendation if you're trying to
predict a movie to a news or there is no
reason to believe that the liking of the
movie liking of the user is going to be
same throughout the day or throughout
the seasons so there can be distribution
shifts and definitely we should be
talking about distribution shifts in
federal learning so that's the goal of
this talk but nowhere we are close to
Optimal we have all the right answers
here uh these are just some motivations
I am not going to talk about all this
slides here so let's jump into the
problem set up first okay so the
problems that I've already was defined
by Naughty so you have like M machines
and each of these machines so this is
like mostly what has been considered in
the prior Works where we consider the
homogeneous or even the heterogeneous
setup so you have some function which we
try to minimize across the machine so
say Capital F1 is the stochastic
objective of machine one and so on F
Capital Alpha and uh these are some
stochastic functions
um there are some distributions which
are
defining its functions but these
distributions are fixed across times so
uh the local machines whatever your
system you have deployed in the local
machines they are playing some points or
some models say xtm at time T so you are
playing this game across three rounds
for this capital m a number of machines
and the regret that we try to minimize
or the objective or the performance
measure that we try to minimize over
this T rounds is essentially like be
competitive whatever we are doing
whatever this xtms however this sequence
of xtm is performing across all these
machines so let's compare its
performance with the best possible model
that you you can have in the hand side
so definitely this is this is a very
weak objective but this might not even
make sense because this is not
personalizing this this might not even
make sense where we are talking about
shifted distributions but that's what we
have we are going to talk about
definitely there is room for improvement
and this is the problem set up the Natty
already spoke about so so we are going
to like generalize it a little more so
instead of assuming that all this
functions I mean sequence of functions
being generated from a fixed
distribution assume that this is
actually generated more adversariately
so this is very strong assumption we
don't need to assume that there is an
adversary which is actually see seeing
the earlier function annual prediction
and then generating the next function
but we are actually studying a very
strong setup we can actually definitely
reduce the strength of this
model and we can assume this FTS are
smoothly changing or like fds have
enough relation across the time steps
all of those we need to discuss more and
I I really appreciate your comment on
that if you have any comments how to
bring this model more realistic
so now we assume that at every time step
T the adversary or whoever they generate
a very adversarial function that this
can be a adaptive function so the
function is Ft FT1 and ft2 FTM for M
machines at time T again the objective
does not change much so we want to be we
want to minimize our regret across all
the machines
um against a fixed comparator X star so
at least we should probably make it x m
star instead of X star but there can be
more more specific objectives we can
look at so we look at this yes
which part is changing over time is it
the F's or the X's
excess ifs are basically changing this
is like the model so it is changing over
time because uh
the way the user is behaving with the
system is also changing so that's what
we are modeling ftn
xtn is how how we are reacting to the
user what we are predicting as a model
to the user so whatever the movie I'm
recomming to the user user or whatever
whatever recommendation system so this
is like my action as a learner and this
is like the user's Behavior okay
okay the exit that you choose will
change but it will change because the
app is changing yeah so I have
definitely yeah it's like I'm trying to
also it's like an online process so I'm
learn also
with different
predictions
okay so that's the objective and uh
you're very please be critical about the
objective because you know this is not
very optimal
um and we will be studying the
intermittent communication model so now
you already mentioned about it
um so we will assume that how this
machines are communicating so the
machines are generally not communicating
this local machines are separate but
only after every K rounds the machines
are allowed to communicate once so
that's the communication module so we
will call it the intermittent
communication model the way the hope to
see is if we actually try to resolve
this problem without any communication
versus if we try to resolve the
communication this problem with this
communication can we do something better
at least at least in some of the regions
all right
so we need to have some sort of
assumptions across some sort of
regularity assumptions or process
functions because
um
yeah there should be some relation
across the machine so the user behaviors
has to be similar some way so we have
some set of assumptions but they might
not be very again realistic to be honest
so the Assumption number one is
basically what we call the bounded
second bounded heterogeneity first order
heterogeneity of assumption we assume
that there is for every single point and
every single time step T the gradient
across the functions do not look very
different okay so we can definitely make
it uh relax assumption more but this is
one of the Assumption we have so we'll
see this whatever this boundedness this
Zeta term is our bound is going to
depend on The Zeta if the Zeta is very
small that means the gradients across
the functions are very similar the
machines are behaving very similarly we
will see improvement in our performance
all right
what is the feedback model I did not
mention about the feedback model so I
said that every user basically behaves
with this the user or the environment is
adversarial so he behaves with this
function F1 F1 t or whatever f t FTI but
what you can query as a system or a
learner is xtm that's that's suppose a
movie or or a point in your decision
space so as a learner you play a point
in the decision piece what you see is
not a gradient but you see only the
evaluation of the function in that point
so say I show you a movie you tell me
like what do you how much you rate the
movie in a scale of 0 to 10 something
like that
so that's why we call it a bandit
feedback and then obviously we have this
intermittent communication
uh
so how to solve this problem
the first thing to try is we can just
try some local best lines so just just
try to be locally optimal and let's see
how does that perform so what does that
mean is you just don't care about the
communication you run your local Bandit
convex optimization algorithms in each
of these machines and this highlighted
part is something you can choose your
favorite Bandit convex optimization
routine here so I can choose whatever my
Flex mental I make my method or more
sophisticated methods that came out
later but wait a minute this none of
this methods depend on AIM because
obviously they are doing all parallel
palette processing but they don't care
about communicating their models so it's
independent of them not good
the next thing we can try doing is very
similar to this Federated averaging kind
of idea where you can start basically
every model
uh zero pointer here
one more minute okay so in every uh
every machine can actually uh play its
own Point XDM and then uh it will query
something around around this wtm that's
basically the point it's bringing you
because we are projecting and uh we can
compute the one point gradient there is
a method to compute one point gradient
estimate from just the standard feedback
so we can compute the gradient and uh
whenever we are not communicating then
we can just do a local gradient present
update in the local machines and when we
are communicating we can just average
out that's the Federated averaging idea
nothing nothing more we are doing here
so
um
the ring right bound here looks
something like this
um when we actually Analyze This
algorithm so let's try to understand
what is the implication of this so let's
try to understand first even a lower
bound of this problem uh suppose if all
the functions are similar the functions
are not even changing across times and
all the functions are actually drawn
from the same distribution so then this
entire regret objective actually boils
down to a stochastic magnet convex
optimization problem for empty many
number of rounds and the lower Bound for
that is something like gbd square root
NT T is KR so can we actually be
competitive with this rate because this
is kind of the very loose low about but
this is this is something definitely a
low amount uh turns out that whatever
the Baseline we use that is definitely
very not at all competitive our
algorithm be competitive for a certain
regime where D is very large but
obviously and and the noise is quite
small because we have a noise term here
if the noise is on and our d is sort of
large enough then we could be completed
with this rate but definitely this
indicator term that we have here is not
optimal which there should be we should
be able to improve this term anyways
okay so I'll just take 30 movement 30
more seconds uh so they're clearly hope
for improvements and we also tried a
slightly different model here this is
not nothing much different so instead of
querying one point I can give you a way
to query a relative feedback for example
you can choose two movies and you can
tell me that how much you prefer a movie
over the other so if you can query two
points X1 and X2 you can uh user would
give me the difference of the function
values so with this I can use a similar
algorithmic idea and with two point
feedback I can have a slightly better
gradient so the rate improves a little
bit so whatever was D becomes square
root D and sometimes vanishes here but
other than that similar problems exist
in the setting uh so that's about it and
there are many open questions with Marty
already talked about we just don't know
what should be a good comparator here
how to model the regularity across of
the functions across the machines and
across time and uh what what is even a
better communication model should we
communicate up to M rounds or only
communicate when the when we actually
believe that the model is not good so it
should be more active communication
and again and you're in privacy foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
and maybe Musharraf can come set up
um just so we don't get too too far off
schedule I think
um
this is the last Talk of the session so
uh Michelle from University of Michigan
uh will be giving this last talk and let
me
I think
because
here
thank you so much for inviting me like
all the things that I heard is very
fascinating but they are all quick to me
I mean in addition to the Greek symbols
like everything is great
um so to get started uh like I'm not
going to talk about sort of the actual
part about research we've been working
on
what is now called Federated learning
before the name Federated learning
existed we called it Geo distributed
analytics uh Planet scale computation
and so on so that's why we never
overlapped and eventually I found that
people are calling it Federated learning
then we started using that then I think
you know uh these folks found me
um so it's mostly led by my student fan
and my colleague Harsha and a lot of
students over the years uh and many
collaborators in Academia and Industry
and we have written a lot of papers in
uh dealing with systems aspects of
communication storage computation
orchestration uh running on the device
running in the cloud aggregation and so
on and so forth but after doing all
these things in early 22 end of 21 sort
of some folks in LinkedIn they are now
read one or two or four papers then they
asked us to come and I don't know give a
talk and sort of asked about okay they
are thinking about implementing uh
cross-device Federated learning they
also have projects on Cross Silo and so
on and so forth and everything I'm going
to discuss is my understanding of
whatever they are doing not necessarily
what LinkedIn actually is doing or want
to do
so why they care about LinkedIn I mean
there are some example applications that
we always see but these are sort of very
concrete three use cases that they had
in mind like in terms of AD and search
these are sort of screenshots of my
LinkedIn app and they want to be able to
re-rank the ads that are being shown so
that the quality improves and even for
the search results after the search
results have been created and come into
my app before they are displayed they
want to train a model that will re-rank
based on my private features and so on
and also especially the messaging part
is sort of I don't know why everything
is like that I don't understand but I
don't know whether anyone can see
clearly and it just looks very broken
here but in any case uh the messages are
end-to-end encrypted and they want to
train this spam and phishing detection
model on encrypted messages by training
them on the device without having to
collect sort of whatever messages the
members are sending back and forth and
they care about privacy and security but
the other thing they cared about is also
sort of not much I have heard about is
performance and cost like to be able to
uh use signals that can actually lead to
very timely changes that's where all of
the re-ranking parts comes in
um and also in terms of cost of course
like if you could distribute work and
instead of using a lot of gpus you can
reduce the number of gpus you need that
will be I don't know cost effective that
may allow people people to try out many
more different models potentially
and of course like we analyze a lot of
traces and data sets and whatever
there's all of all sorts of
heterogeneity that we have heard too
much about they are all happen to be
sort of tied together for individual
user they have a specific data specific
type of device specific availability
pattern and they are not really
independent so everything has to be
considered together but the part as a
systems researcher I found very
interesting actually even for me was
very surprising is the usability of the
system is much more important and trumps
everything else because there are sort
of many different stakeholders and we
have to make sure that the users of the
app they feel like the experience they
are having did not become worse probably
improved the app developers which is
another set of people who are developing
the app they're trying to make it really
Snappy their sort of expectation is that
whatever competition whatever is
happening is not going to make things
slow so they don't have to go back go
back and rerun and re-optimize the app
and the ml developers were designing
sort of more else they already have a
lot of tool chain and workflow they
don't want to go back and redo and
rewrite everything from scratch so they
want to use all of the existing tool
chains so
they thought about fit scale because
it's sort of like a a platform where you
can simulate but you can also sort of
actually run the same code in a
distributed fashion you can plug in sort
of data traces and system traces and
different types of model which all of
the plots that I plotted earlier they
were collected by Linkin and they could
plug in their own data to quickly
simulate and see what is expected to
happen and they wanted to evaluate sort
of many different ways of training many
algorithms optimizers quickly without
having to actually deploy them because
once you deploy people notice and it's
sort of very risky and you have to
quickly get a sense of how much resource
and what type of performance you expect
and so that they can plan and so that is
sort of one of the big thing and here
are a quick segue to what uh
fed scale uh is a sort of a collection
of lot of data sets that goes beyond
sort of the common data set people use
some of them are much larger with
millions of clients and also the runtime
itself is pretty scalable and fall
tournament so you can run on these uh
sort of data sets in a scalable fashion
so that's where they started and I don't
know whether you notice and I'm going
really quickly so feel free to
eventually stop me and ask questions is
that some of the data set they wanted to
earn a train on were like 16 million uh
sort of population and so it's like
massive and you need a runtime that can
I don't know scale and actually work uh
efficiently so the other part is this
they already have this Cloud ml platform
which they have built over maybe I don't
know a decade and all of the pieces we
don't have to go over all of it is like
I don't know people know it's just that
they want this Flint which is the
Federated part FL integration in
LinkedIn has to coexist with this thing
it cannot not exist separately because
people don't want to maintain two
systems people don't want to learn two
different things and the other part of
Flint which actually is not in this
mlc's paper is sort of it will be
provided as a service where their first
party apps are going to use Federated
learning but they will also create an
SDK that will be exposed to sort of
their Downstream customers which are not
really uh sort of the users but rather
so that they can also do Federated
learning and analytics potentially
depending on how things have been set up
so it's sort of like actually building
Federated learning at a service where
all of the clients are sort of like
compute device that are distributed
potentially again and that is uh used by
completely sort of
um outside third parties to build their
app integrate in their app to run
computation and learn knowledge about it
sort of you can think of it's akin to
like Cloud but it's a this Federated
type of cloud and so for for all of
these three use cases they I don't know
did some simulation in this I don't know
platform and are evaluation on the
actual data set and actual traces and
they found that it actually performs
pretty well even with Federated learning
the performance is within two percent of
whatever fully centralized cloud
training they are doing there are a lot
of details in the paper that I would not
want to talk about one of the thing I
want to highlight is that which we also
didn't do when we were doing fit scale
and we didn't think of is that they use
this um sort of they build a subsystem
which relies on the AWS device form
where they have like a bunch of many
different mobile devices and browser
which typically UI ux people use to test
like how their mobile whatever apps and
whatnot will look like in variety of
devices but they actually use that to
run this many different sort of small
models that they plan on actually
deploying on the device and train them
or run a few iteration and then actually
see like what type of performance and
memory requirement and CPU reprogram and
so on and so forth you can see there's a
bit the build up a sort of very nice
infrastructure where you can submit a
model and it will go and run on this 27
or however many different types of
devices you will collect all the stats
so you will know okay maybe this model
is too big and it's probably not going
to run on 33 percent of the phones and
this model is I don't know maybe like
actually small enough and can run within
whatever constraints have been said by
the ml uh sort of the app developers but
maybe the accuracy of the model which is
coming from the other side is poor so
you need to consider all of these
different multi-faceted constraints and
then come up with a solution what can be
done so I'm going to stop here and the
main lessons I learned is that like I
didn't know about like all of these
different types of people even as a
systems researcher that the app
developers and the ml developers and
know their sort of the PMS they have
like very different things that they
care about and convincing everybody is
extremely hard like uh we've been I
don't know I mean at this point it's
more than a year is moving slowly that's
why it's stored and it's not really I
mean in production yet it's a lot of
steps we have gone through and there are
a lot of things to go through and more
than sort of even theoretical guarantees
people care about sort of understanding
what is going on just so when things
break they can try to explain or who to
blame I think is very important and also
I having some sort of predictable
behavior is also very important that
doesn't necessarily mean like I don't
know theoretical results are not useful
it's just that I mean people who are
actual Engineers they either don't
understand or don't really have time to
even appreciate they just want I know
like this is their day job so they have
to you know keep going to the next day
and they just want to make sure the
things are learning and FL or
Collaborative Learning whatever we are
going to call it uh has to probably
coexist with Cloud uh for a while if not
forever and so it is probably going to
be a combined version of two there is no
competition between this versus that
it's probably going to be this and that
and uh I'll stop there and if you have
any questions I don't know whether I was
too fast great yeah thank you thank you
[Applause]
if you budgeted yourself for a question
yeah
for developers
can you tell us a little bit about the
LinkedIn it's like who would use it um
like who are linkedin's Downstream
customers you talked about third-party
people yeah who are the third party so I
mean right now they already have an SDK
where uh sort of all the different types
of data they collect from their users
that are sort of available for these
different providers maybe ad networks uh
maybe I don't know people who are trying
to run a campaign on LinkedIn but they
want to understand doing some analysis
and analytics on what type of people
doing whatever so they can better Target
their ad campaign and a variety of other
things I don't really know like all the
business details of what not and again
this is my understanding of what is
there but not necessarily whatever is
actually going on but my understanding
is that they ideally if possible like uh
to move as much as possible in a very
distributed setup if they could make
sure that it would be fully private and
it's fully secure so that's why privacy
and security are very important
especially when you allow third-party
people who are on a program against and
train on and understand user data so I
mean all of the parts also are sort of
pending like where they are very
confident that no one can actually
extract things out and also like
designing the interface itself and what
type of computation can or shooter
should not be allowed there's a lot of
research to be done I think just from a
basic systems perspective like how to
limit and restrict so people cannot do
more than what is enabled so just like
general purpose computation probably is
not a good idea so it has to be very
restricted limited set of operations
that are performed and may not even be
learning for third party could be just
analytics just trying to understand
certain things of distribution and not
just an arbitrary computation that may
actually slow down the app which will
actually hurt LinkedIn app itself yeah
uh maybe one one quick question and then
we'll I'm just kind of curious like what
your measure of success is like is being
within two percent of uh the cloud ml
algorithm that's that's a win because we
save money and we have to train out the
cloud is success mean oh we should be
able to use private features and be two
percent better or five percent better
like how do you I mean it depends on
sort of uh whether it's
two percent in words or twenty percent
better it remains to be same because
this is assuming like in a world where a
lot of things are being collected and I
think the preparation is for the day
where the cookies will be banned and app
tracking is already closed and many
other regulation may come out I don't
know five years later then whatever we
are saying two person works is actually
probably 20 better because nothing is
and the things that people who are like
I mean gotten used to collecting
um so it's it's unclear because it's
it's unclear what will become
unavailable and how much that will
affect like today centralized MLS or no
accuracy uh but I mean as long as it's
within the ballpark or whatever is
happening today it seems reasonable
because you haven't all I mean two
person is actually very big it's not
really small so it's it's not I I
wouldn't make any business calls myself
on this uh it's just that uh at least
like um
it was not so bad that they would think
that okay let's not even bother about it
for a few more years and wait and see I
think two percent I mean they were
expecting probably even more and when we
have two person like same like everyone
including people here are pretty excited
that it's like pretty close and even if
you lose certain signals if you cannot
be within two person or whatever it is
immediately and of course things will
improve that is that hope as well
um they'll be happy
all right thanks again
uh so we're gonna take a 10 minute break
so we can come back for the working
group session around 11 25.